[Music]
ryan is with us in fresno hi ryan
welcome to the ramsay show
hi how's it going good man what's up
all right so question for you
i
made a
non-dave decision about four years ago
and i need your help getting out of it
okay
that's an interesting way of saying it
non-dave meaning it was a bad decision
well thanks for the compliment but
how can i help what tell me what
happened
yeah so uh my wife and i
went in on a property
with her
sister and
her husband
and it's 20 acres it has a primary house
and it had a mobile home on it
so my wife and i we took the primary
house
and
they took the mobile home it was all
agreed upon everything good
um
we decided to split the ownership
50 50.
you split 50 50 but they get the trailer
that was uh what we agreed on you're a
good negotiator
[Laughter]
uh yeah so i pay a little bit more for
homeowners insurance just because we are
in the primary house
we have to have two
separate homeowners insurance just i
don't know that's how they worked it out
anyways
my brother-in-law
they
either want us to all sell this place
together
or they want
me to buy him out
and we can't come
to an agreement on how we want to do
that we
basically our relationship is
showered
and
so we're we're kind of at a standstill
of
how we
how we can go about it um that's sad
yeah i don't know if i i don't know how
much help i can be with the relationship
part um
there's a i have a couple of thoughts on
structure if you want those you went
into it 50 50. so why don't you just
have the property appraised and pay him
50 percent
um
hello let's say
yeah can you hear me yeah can you hear
me oh
yes okay why don't you have an
apprentice
you put in 50 you each put in 50 right
and he got the short end of the stick
and lived in the trailer
all right yeah and now he wants to buy
out why can't you pay him 50 of the
value what's wrong with that
well the the value is somewhere around
400 000 yeah
and uh so that would mean
so how does that mean i'm paying him 200
000 or just
he owns 50 of it he bought 50 of it you
bought 50 of it
we don't we don't own the home outright
though
we're still paying on a mortgage
okay
together
yeah
okay then it's 400 000
minus the mortgages divided by two
okay uh so if it that you're saying the
total 20 acres and the two the house and
the trailer are worth 400 grand is that
what you're telling me
yeah okay and how much is the mortgage
uh we owe about 320 on it okay you're
gonna have to get that refinance to get
his name off of it for him to be free
but you've only got eighty thousand
dollars worth of equity you need to
write him a check for 40.
not really i'll come to that in a minute
but you're half you buy out his half
what's
why is that complicated
i just i don't want to go into even
more
debt
i'm just i think i'm having trouble
figuring out how to i'm paying him 40
000
and then accruing
the remaining balance of the mortgage
yeah but you also own the property 100
okay
okay instead of owning a 200 dollar
property now you own a four hundred
thousand dollar property
that's good okay and so uh can you
handle the mortgage by yourself i think
that might be the problem
uh
yes yes i can what's your household
income
uh last year brought in about 72
okay
you can't afford this
this payment by yourself can you
that's your household income you and
your wife
yeah my wife's to stay at home okay
we have a uh we
run a small family ranch where we live
yeah i'm sorry sir i don't think you can
afford a four hundred thousand dollar
mortgage or three hundred something
thousand dollar mortgage
150 000 mortgage on a 72 000 income
i don't think that's going to work well
for you your payment when you take this
out on a 15-year fix should be no more
than a fourth of your income i think you
guys are selling this property i want to
revisit the last caller because i had a
thought all right the break
a solution okay so let's revisit he and
uh his wife's sister and his
brother-in-law the four of them bought a
property together 20 acres
uh they live in fresno california and it
has a trailer on it and a home on it
they moved into the home the
brother-in-law moved into the trailer uh
the brother something's gone sour and
the brother-in-law wants out he wants
out of the deal they both put in fifty
percent so the property is currently
valued at four hundred thousand
and they owe 320. those were the facts
going into the break okay
um
he makes 75 000 a year he can't afford
the payment on the whole thing if he
buys his brother-in-law out
uh it was my point going to the break so
that sounds like they're going to be
forced to sell out of the whole thing i
did have another way because he's he
also said i think he's ranching on that
property he's so his
i was not only getting rid of his house
i was getting rid of his job his sole
income yeah everything i mean his whole
life's upside down so um i hated to just
throw him on the bus head into a
commercial break
so here is a thought for ryan
um
you can subdivide 20 acres
and take the 10
that you want to keep and the 10 that
the brother-in-law keeps
the brother-in-law sells his 20 acres or
his 10 acres and the trailer
is on that
he takes that money
pays half of the mortgage off because
he's liable for half of the mortgage the
mortgage is 320 so that puts it at 180.
did i do that right no no well
320 and a half is not one that's 160.
thank you i'm the money guy keep it keep
this in mind i was a little nervous
heading into that to be honest with you
i did some quick math myself i was like
before i questioned dave i thought i
thought i thought dave yeah had to take
my shoes off under the desk and use my
toes
okay so 160 000 yeah all right so
brother-in-law pays off 160 000 right
whatever's left from the sale of the 10
acres after he pays off 160 000 he puts
in his pocket and walks away
i like that he's just been bought out
now then ryan has to go get a new
mortgage for 160 000
only owns 10 acres has no money out of
pocket
and um
he can put that on a 15 year and survive
making 75 000 that's right but you're
not going to have 20 acres ryan you're
going to have 10 acres
subdivided
10 acres each brother-in-law sells his
takes these money proceeds for the sale
pays off half of the mortgage
simultaneously ryan's gonna have to get
a new mortgage at the same closing table
for 160 000 to give clear title to the
new buyer on the 10 acres
the buyer on the 10 acres
and the brother is going to get whatever
if he sells that for 400 grand yeah he
whatever the brother can sell his
brother-in-law can sell his 10 acres for
he gets that money yeah minus 160. he
has to pay off his half of the mortgage
and then ryan can keep his property but
he's only going to keep the 10 acres
which is all he ever had to start with
right because it was a partnership on 20
acres yeah so um now if ryan needs 20
acres to run his ranch
i don't think he can afford it there's
the problem yep that's the only asterisk
there on that one yeah so um
and you're going to have to find a way
to subdivide this but in most counties
in the united states of america you can
subdivide 20 down into 10.
very few places keep you from doing that
and sell it off and then the
brother-in-law got what he got and
that's his half you don't have to argue
about what it's worth he let the market
tell him what it's worth yeah
but he has to bring 160 out for his half
of the mortgage all right now we got
there i feel better about that solution